we do have to start things on a somber
note because alex trebek passed away at
the age of 80 yesterday
he passed away at home surrounded by his
family of course he was very public
about his battle with stage four
pancreatic cancer
he was optimistic about his treatment
and he did beat the odds for quite a
while
yes and he kept on hosting jeopardy
right up until the end
uh he taped his last episode just on
october 29 just a little over a week
before he passed away
that last episode will air on christmas
day the executive producer of jeopardy
was on
cnn yesterday and abc aired a 2020
special last night with one of
uh the last interviews with alex here
are a few contestants showing their love
for alex in the past few months
let's take a look at your response did
you come up with the right one no
what is we love you out that's very kind
thank you
costco 19.95
you're left with five bucks okay any
family members
back home uh cheering you on you know
here's a true story man
i grew up i learned english because of
you and so
my grandfather who who raised me i'm
going to get tears right now he
we i used to sit on his lap and watch
you every day so
it's a pretty special moment for me man
thank you very much
stop worrying about the future just
treat every day
as a blessing and try to
be aware of when you leave
this earth that you've made a difference
in the lives of other people
a positive difference that is one thing
that has changed about me
because of the cancer i'm more keenly
aware
of accomplishing that in my lifetime
he was the most professional person that
i've ever worked with
in in any capacity here he was battling
cancer
pain chemo exhaustion
but you couldn't tell when the when the
cameras rolled
so as a professional the fact that he
kept pushing and that he recorded
his final what would now be his final
episodes um
less than two weeks ago it gives you an
idea of
just how much he believed in the show
how much he cared for it i had chills
the entire uh the entire tape day
um that first show of that that final
week which is the
unbelievably the week of christmas he
gives a speech
um talking about togetherness how
important family is
and it will resonate even more now i it
was so beautiful
that we were all emotion emotional we
were all in tears
and we all started clapping and it
almost distracted him because
he was going okay now let's play
jeopardy
um but it was it was one of those days
it was just
he was at the top of his game even
though
clearly he was very ill i've had such a
good life
there is no possibility of
any regrets in my mind
or in my heart so i'm happy
[Music]
yeah so some celeb reaction to this of
his passing ryan reynolds revealed alex
actually shot a scene
in his upcoming movie alex trebek was
kind enough to film a
a cameo for our film free guy last year
despite his battle
he was gracious and funny in addition to
being curious stalwart
generous reassuring and of course
canadian we love you alex and always
will
jimmy kimmel tweeted can we have one
nice weekend a kind gentleman whose
excellent was so consistent
it was easy to take for granted rest
well mr trebek
ryan seacrest said alex rebecca was like
a family member who i watched every
night
i remember going to the set to watch him
tape a show before i started started my
tv career
he was a big influence and one of a kind
rest in peace alex
of course pat sajak wrote alex trebek's
courage grace and strength inspired
millions
and all those of us who knew him a
tremendous loss for his family friends
co-workers and countless viewers
i was honored to be a friend and a part
of his professional family for all these
years
a very sad day yeah canadian prime
minister justin trudeau tweeted
we have lost an icon almost every night
for more than three decades alex trebek
entertained and educated millions around
the world
instilling in so many of us a love for
trivia my deepest condolences to his
family friends and all who are mourning
this tremendous loss michelle i feel
like you're someone that could identify
with what he said there about
wanting to make a a positive impact in
people's lives
is that something you relate to yeah
well first of all my condolences to alex
trebek he's a staple
in the maple man definitely a national
treasure and i grew up watching him too
as well but something that he said
really resonated guys
is like tomorrow's never promised so you
want the most of it yeah
and that's for him for him to say he's
got no regrets
about his life that means he didn't take
a day for granted
and i think that's very important
especially in times like this and these
trying times of uncertainty
that when you're around loved ones the
picture that that really resonated with
me is with his family right there
because yeah you know we're only here
for a minute man impact are you gonna
make on the world
while we're here and alex trebek
definitely made a positive impact
even the thought of not having him
around anymore we take for granted
sometimes even the people that we see
on television or the people that we know
from media i mean he's been around for
again hosting jeopardy for 37 years
he's been hosting it for as long as i've
been alive pretty much
and uh you know like those clips we saw
in the beginning of the contestants
getting choked up uh i think a lot of us
sort of share that experience of
knowing alex trebek from being kids
growing up watching him as we grew up as
well it's uh yeah it's a very sad loss
yeah it's crazy that definitely yeah
just he kept filming until october 29th
so only about yeah about
nine days before he passed away who's
still doing jeopardy and that's what
we've talked about before with
even his his uh fight against this the
idea he was
always still the professional he was
still the host he was still doing all
his
you know health updates on set of
jeopardy and like presenting them like a
host who's just that
consummate professional like you're just
it's such a huge loss you're just such a
professional
such a hero to so many people yeah i'll
just read some
comments here taffy says alex trebek was
a legend kristen says oh alex what a
loss it's a true class
act i watch him every day nelson says
pretty big that even trudeau said
something
um sarah says rest in peace alex
um shell says he died on my birthday uh
yeah ashraf says we're having such a
great week with biden winning and this
had to happen 2020 just won't give us a
break
she also is such a sweet man jeremiah
says my childhood
is slowly passing we'll miss him yeah i
mean we've had a lot of huge names die
in uh 2012 watching them easier
yeah and that's like sean connery just
passed away last week too so yeah it's
been
it's been a tough year yeah but i mean
that's like you said meister what a life
he had a great life like
it's very sad to see him go but what a
life he had he really was a very happy
man loved what he did
loved his family and like he said in
that clip i mean he couldn't ask for
for more so yeah he really had a great
life yeah we're gonna miss alex trebek
rest in peace absolutely yeah